i'm alex crawford my name's stuart  ramsey i'm the chief correspondent of  sky news my job as foreign correspondent  takes me all over the world  latin america the far east the middle  east  africa europe i've been to yemen syria  lebanon in the past few weeks and now  i'm in the united states we're bringing  you the best of sky news in your  language  it's certainty in a more and more  uncertain world and that doesn't just  mean the  english-speaking world coronavirus us  politics  climate change all of these are  international events which have  a global impact we want to bring you  that news fast  but there's a lot more analysis  documentaries  we want to tell you what we see hear and  feel  we want to bring you the best of sky  news in your language  it's clarity clarity in an uncertain  world  in an uncertain world